people across Europe are struggling to
pay soaring energy bills but the EU
can't agree on capping the price of
natural gas which is a short supply due
to Russia's war in Ukraine so what can
leaders do to prevent a winter of
discontent this is Inside Story
[Music]
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
I'm Laura Kyle time is running out for
Europe to contain soaring natural gas
prices Russia was the continent's main
provider until it invaded Ukraine
earlier this year sanctions and
disruptions to pipelines such as the
nordstream one in the Baltic Sea have
dented supplies so households and
businesses are being forced to pay
several times more than usual
European union leaders have been meeting
in the Czech Republic to discuss ways to
keep costs down ahead of winter 15
member states want an eu-wide price cap
on gas but others including Germany and
the Netherlands are against this Germany
is focusing on subsidies to protect its
own businesses and consumers neighboring
Poland says that's not fair for the rest
of the block and the head of the
European Commissioners urging members to
unite behind a common plan
time and again the single Market has
proven to be our single best asset in
times of crisis
therefore we need to preserve it it's of
Paramount importance that we have a
Level Playing Field and that we avoid
fragmentation and distortion
on the contrary we have to make possible
that there are investments we have to
double down on investments in homegrown
Renewables not only for the climate but
also because the transition to the clean
energy is the best way to gain
independence and to have security of
energy Supply
well the EU has already agreed other
measures to reduce demand and protect
supplies these include a so-called
solidarity levy on energy companies
excess profits and a cap on revenues
made by non-gas electricity producers a
mandatory five percent cut on
electricity consumption during peak
hours until March next year and a
voluntary 10 reduction to be decided by
each member State many have already set
standard limits Italy and Spain have
ordered a maximum temperature of 19
degrees Celsius for central heating
whilst Germany has turned off hot water
in public buildings and France has even
put speed limits on ski lifts and is
producing less artificial snow
well soaring energy bills and Rising
living costs have triggered protests
across major European cities in the past
few months and this was a dominant issue
in the recent elections in Italy and
Sweden after a step vassen has more from
one protest in Prague
well this is the largest Trade union
rally in 10 years and thousands of
factory workers have taken to the street
here in Prague to protest against
poverty that's how they call this rally
and we are meeting here factory workers
from all kinds of Industries some metal
industry the textile industry
Communications even the medical workers
are here and they're all complaining
about the high prices because the Czech
Republic has one of the hardest to the
largest inflation rates in Europe more
than 70 percent and people are really
struggling to pay their bills and what
these unions are asking for is control
of prices by the government not only
food but also fuel they want the price
gap on gas because the Czech Republic
was 400 depending on Russian gas before
and now they try to import gas from
everywhere and the costs are
tremendously high so that's what they're
asking for and many many more people are
expected to come here today they told
everyone 50 000 maybe up to 70 000 would
be coming step faster for altazira
Inside Story
let's bring in our guests now and in
antwer Rebecca Christie a non-resident
fellow at brugel that's a brussels-based
economic think tank in London Max Lawson
head of Oxfam International's inequality
policy program and in barranquila
Colombia Anna Maria makarevic she's an
energy analyst for the Europe team of
the institute for energy economics and
financial analysis a warm welcome to all
of you Anna Maria let's start with
looking at these different price caps
there's all sorts of different proposals
on the tables what are they and why
can't EU countries agree on them
hi uh they are very different they all
are aiming to secure some type of gas uh
to the system to the to the to the
continent uh but they like coordination
they like they lack a smart
unsustainable solution for the continent
they all want some of them want to cup
on the energy that is imported others
own reducing what the
consumer is paid but then uh there's
another ones that they want kind of a
mixture between them because it's
difficult uh if we if we put a cap on
the price we are going to pay for the
gas we could have uh we have a great
competition outside and perhaps some
countries are worried that they will uh
lose buyers yeah that they would like to
sell to them uh so it's it's not an easy
solution each con each each country has
their own needs and what we need is a
coordinated action that will be
beneficial for all the continents so
we're back we've got 15 member states
wanting an EU wide price cap but Germany
and the Netherlands are against that why
is that particularly
I think you're talking about a price cap
on natural gas which is of interest
because natural gas is not affected by
the sanctions that have been put in
place on Russia if anything Russia has
been de facto putting uh gas related
sanctions on the EU through limiting
Supply and as a consequence of all the
technical issues with the pipelines so
you have the issue of what consumers and
wholesalers are paying for natural gas
and whether it's best to have a market
signal a subsidy some sort of regulated
market how you're going to help Europe
get through the winter this is very
different from the oil price cap that
the EU is trying to put specifically on
Russian oil perhaps as an alternative to
ending all exports of Russian oil so
they're very different caps with very
different goals and it seems Rebecca
that countries are tending to Veer
towards taking their own approach and
this is upsetting EU Unity how difficult
is it to reach census because they are
very different countries with very
different needs
when you talk about taking your own
approach you really I believe talking
about energy security and how each
country is looking to handle its
domestic responsibilities in terms of
keeping the heat on and the lights on
and that's very
going to affects budgets some countries
are able to borrow more in public
markets than others and it's very tricky
to coordinate all this stuff in a way
that pays for it and that doesn't cause
other people to feel like they're paying
for their neighbors
Max this is a very it's not an easy
issue to manage is it even if you are
doing it country by country can you
explain the rate at which these Energy
prices are spiraling and the impact that
it's having on the people
well I think you know for Oxford we work
with four people all over the world but
also with very poor people in Europe in
Spain here in the UK it's hard to
exaggerate the impact of these prices I
was just reading today about how we
already here in the UK have four million
people using food banks so food
Charities that give out food because
people are hungry many many people are
now coming and saying please give us
food that is cold that you you don't
have to cook because they're unable even
here in October at the beginning of the
winter to afford the energy to even cook
the free food that they're getting so
it's hard to exaggerate the pain at the
bottom but it's also hard to exaggerate
the profits at the top you've got an
energy industry that's making around
three billion dollars of profit a day
you've got 72 new food and energy
billionaires that's 72 new billionaires
on top of the existing billion is in the
oil gas and Food Industries so enormous
profits being made enormous winners too
in this situation so something has to
give we need to see those winners
contribute far more to helping the
people at the bottom Anna Maria would
you not say that those winners are
helping to address those wealth
inequalities I mean we're looking at
many countries already bringing in a
windfall tax on profits yeah there are
all helping but maybe just one solution
is not enough we all have to work as I
said in other times I've said we need to
bring solutions that will tackle three
main things that are energy security any
transition goals and cost so any
solution that comes into place have to
bring a wider uh benefit to all the
communities and yes they are helping but
just one solution won't be enough they
need to also work on the demand side and
that's the part that I am struggling to
see in Europe that all these are
Solutions are mainly from the supply
side now they're analyzing all the
products that we have on the supply
issues but I want to see programs
immediately starting in all Europe on
how to switch demand how can we bring
for example heating Heating in a
sustainable way because that is the
worry now that we are going to come into
December uh winter is coming we need
Heating and majority of the countries
they have they use gas for central
heating so I I would I would like that
we bring Solutions on the demand side
because we are just focusing supply side
Max to what to extent do you agree with
that that consumers and businesses
should be responsible as well for this
by reducing their demand I mean I I
think in the UK it might be one of the
few countries in Europe that is not
requiring its people to change their
behavior of consumption of electricity
I think I would agree but let's again be
careful of the tyranny of averages when
we say consumers in the UK we're talking
about a hugely unequal country so do I
think Rich consumers should massively
reduce their consumption of energy even
in normal times
absolutely you know the richest 10 20 of
every country in Europe dominate the use
of carbon the use of energy and it's
using far far more carbon than they
could if we're going to save the planet
so I think we need to be careful saying
that all consumers need to somehow
tighten their belts we think of those
people at the bottom in rented
accommodation one in five uh deaths from
cold in in winter here in the UK these
are very poor people often elderly so I
don't think we should really be telling
them to uh conserve energies I think
let's be really specific about who we
mean here it's the people at the top in
every society that are massively over
consuming energy in Europe Rebecca what
are your thoughts on that because as we
just heard Italy and Spain for example
ordering a maximum temperature of 19
degrees Celsius for central heating it
doesn't sound very high do you think
that makes enough of a difference to
Warrant it
reducing demand certainly will help and
then the other question is how countries
can help make sure they're most
vulnerable are getting assistance this
is something that makes to me more sense
than just regulating the entire market
and lowering prices that even very
wealthy people can benefit from instead
you leave the prices High to encourage
people who might have a choice about how
much they spend on energy to spend less
and then you provide direct Aid to the
people in less fortunate circumstances
who just need help getting by but
Rebecca this is what Germany is doing is
that it's created this 200 billion
dollar Aid package which will help
people with their soaring energy bills
but it's coming under massive fire from
other parts of Europe that are saying
that it's just going out on its own and
it's creating unfair competition in a
single Market
there's a lot of concern that a country
like Germany that has a lot of fiscal
space is benefiting without sharing the
wealth that people across the EU believe
comes from the single Market as a whole
so there's a feeling that Germany would
do better to use its economic power to
help the entire continent rather than
simply focusing within its own borders
and leaving other people do the same
given how critical Germany is of the way
other people spend their own money and
also EU finances there's a lot to be
said for helping vulnerable populations
there's a lot to be said for looking for
ways to structure Aid and to structure
Market incentives that the market will
work but it needs to be done in a way
that people believe is fair that
political perception is important Anna
Maria you mentioned that demand is
important but caps whilst they may ease
the cost they certainly don't restrain
demand do they so there's it's kind of
dichotomy there as to how good and how
how well they will be received
but I would encourage more switching gas
demand for example there are
alternatives for heating that is one of
the issues that are the main worry right
now for the winter seasons why don't we
encourage more the buying uh heat pumps
installing heat pumps at homes you know
uh maybe solar panels for heating so so
the demand could be managed in a
different ways and I think that's why we
need more technical aspects not just the
financial part you know we need to
understand okay how is the system works
how we need to understand also properly
our Network how is the Gas and energy
behaves the network in all Europe to
understand where can we move uh flows
around where can the demand be
distributed in different places and what
can the government's help do to switch
those consumers their demand that
they're having with gas to order
Sustainable Solutions all the renewal
sources yeah so I think I think it's not
just Financial we need to work on things
legal issues here Max this is an
opportunity isn't it to speed up
development in the area of Renewables
and in the longer term Renewables should
be more energy and cost efficient across
the board
oh I mean absolutely we need to
transition faster but I think we need to
be very careful in describing what's
happening right now in Europe as an
opportunity I mean the huge suffering a
huge chunk of the people at the bottom
of the economic pyramid remember they
don't own their own homes they're
renting their own homes you know the
idea that they can somehow find a heat
pump and replace their rickety gas
heating I mean in the immediate future
we need to stop old people dying of cold
in the next two or three months and I
think we need to be very very careful in
presenting this as some kind of
opportunity okay but do I think that we
need to structurally transition as rich
countries away from fossil fuels and
could this leaving us in a position
where we we do that quicker I hope so
but right now I'm much more worried
about stopping people dying of coal so
if we're looking across Europe which
countries can you point to to be doing a
good job so far at protecting the most
vulnerable in our societies this winter
I think the Spanish government is doing
a good job I think they're implementing
a
semi-universal basic income which they
were before they're now talking about
wealth taxes as well as windfall taxes
it is true we're seeing windfall taxes
being implemented but they're not high
enough you know uh during World War II
and in other crises we've seen windfall
taxes of up to 90 95 on excessive
profits remember these are profits being
made above normal so it's not on all
profits it's on the profits they're
making excessively so these windfall
taxes could be much much higher and we
could also see taxes on the richest
people in the last two three years uh
starting with covid-19 and now with the
food and energy crisis you've seen an
explosion in wealth at the very top
across the rich world so people are much
much better off at the very top so I
think Spain needs to be congratulated
for thinking about wealth taxes as well
as windfall taxes at the opposite
extreme we have our government here in
the UK which seems to have picked the
worst moment in history to give away
enormous sums of money to the very rich
and I think they're suffering
politically as a result so yes a huge
variety across the continent of what
governments are doing and you know
inequality is a poverty inequality in
poverty are a policy choice you know
people dying of cold that's a policy
Choice it doesn't have to happen in
Europe this winter Rebecca when people
are unhappy they can express it through
protests they can reflect it in The
Ballot Box if they get the opportunity
to what extent you think Europe is going
to see the more extremist politicians in
their political structures capitalizing
on this malaise
we certainly see big political shifts
and we certainly see voters pushing for
Change and looking for something
different it remains to be seen whether
outside politicians will adopt extreme
positions once they're in government or
if they will try to govern at least
somewhat toward the center Italy is of
course where all eyes are right now you
mentioned taxes uh Georgia Maloney has
said she and her party would like to
lower the tax burden on ordinary
citizens and lower the labor tax burden
Italy has one of the highest ones and
yet find ways to keep the country's
economy going so it may be that she'll
be able to do this and move toward the
center it may also be that rather than
focus on these sorts of economic
measures there'll just be a lot of
frustration and measures designed to
draw out that frustration and that would
be worrisome Anna Maria it may seem
simple to ask but why can the supplies
that we've lost from Russia simply not
be replaced with other supplies from
Norway from Qatar from the US you may
think there's plenty in the world to go
around so why can't it not just be
diverted to where it's needed
okay first of all we are we were
importing 150 BCM from Russia via
pipeline is a closest uh country to
Europe and then pipeline uh transport is
cheaper than LNG
um there's uh there's enough there's a
lot of gas around but they are all
already sold in long-term contracts so
most of those contracts are already
signed years ago they say Qatar with
their their own uh
it's buyers they have already signed
contract so it's not that you can just
come and say Yes I want all these you
need also interested you're to import
gas and that's but that's when I when I
really uh encourage Europe to be a smart
that not just build build you know for
the sake of because we need more energy
terminals we have the case of Spain for
example they built more than 10 years
ago a lot of energy terminals that they
didn't need it they haven't needed it
and even if they can't if they can
export more to Europe there's there
won't still be all utilized could be
maybe 60 maximum so that's what we don't
want we don't want the stranded assets
you know we want we want that whatever
is used in a uh in Spain in Europe it
will be uh sustainable for the future
and then that's that's the thing you
cannot just bring immediately all the
all the production from other parts
because they need also to invest in
production and they need to switch uh
buyers we have a big issue right now
with Asia for example there are some
buyers in Asia that they're struggling
to pay for the high LNG prices that
Europe can pay so then we are also
having a difference uh as we say in
wealth in other countries that is
affecting their energy needs so we are
seeing also energy poverty coming into
other places in the world so it's very
it's it's let's say allergy is behaving
now as a world commodity yeah where all
the things are affected and then we have
seen sadly you know this year as
systematically on reliability of all the
gas value chain we saw for example few
days ago Malaysian energy had a problem
with their exporting terminals their
main buyer is one of them is Japan
similarly Japan tries to cure long-term
contracts the government is giving them
so long to do it okay so everybody in
the world wants that yeah yeah Rebecca
we just haven't got much time left I
just want to point out that the EU has
mostly scrambled to get enough gas to
cover this winter but what about next
winter
next winter is a big question
um it'd be nice to get through this
winter first as you point out Europe has
filled up its reserves so the question
now is will it be able to refill them
once it uses them and that will depend
on a lot of these policies we've been
discussing today and Max what happens
when people are simply unable or refuse
to pay their bills what happens then
well I mean I think there's a mass
protest building in in many parts of
Europe certainly here in the UK about
people refusing to pay and I think a lot
of people won't be able to pay and I
think there will be an increase in debts
and ultimately a lot of suffering as I
said
um you know one in five old people dying
from cold here in the UK just last
winter you know real real suffering
around the continent and completely
unavoidable this is a policy Choice by
governments lets tax corporations
effectively and fairly let's tax very
rich people and let's protect the
poorest okay invest in that transition I
think that's what we need to do Urgent
Anna Marie just in the last 30 seconds
will the EU do that
hopefully yes okay all right and there
we will leave our discussion today thank
you very much for taking the time to
join us Rebecca Christie Max Lawson and
Anna Maria makarevic
and thank you to for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion do go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story you can
also join the conversation on Twitter we
are at AJ inside story from me Laura
Kyle and the whole team here in Doha bye
for now
[Music]